I think this is an exciting trial, at least in the Waldenstrom's world, because this is a treatment that we've seen so far that can potentially overcome some of the mutations that occur in Waldenstrom.
So, as I mentioned briefly yesterday, patients can have CXCR4 mutations or develop TP53 mutations, and with our standard therapies with BTK inhibitors and venetoclax, often the impact of those therapies can be different, or the therapy efficacy can be different depending on those mutations.
So, Lankas, Texamab, Tesserine, it's a CD19 antibody drug conjugate.
It is FDA approved and refrigerated.
It's directed at a large B-cell lymphoma, but we thought it was a good agent to be using in Waldenstrom's because there are no prior data with CD19-targeted therapies in Waldenstrom's.
But the lymphocytes in Waldenstrom's that we see in the bone marrow are CD19-positive, typically, and also the plasma cell component of Waldenstrom's is typically CD19-positive.
So, we thought we would pursue this trial.
You can see the statistical information below, but we're aiming for a sample size of 20 patients.
And...
And the null hypothesis would be rejected if at least six patients achieved a VGPR, which you'll see in the coming slides, that we did meet the endpoint of this trial.
And we saw much deeper responses than we actually expected to see.
This is data on the first 14 valuable patients, although I'll update you now because we haven't enrolled the 20 patients.
So, Lankas, Texamab has a standard dosing of 150 micrograms per kilo in cycles 1 and 2, and then it's reduced to 75 micrograms after that.